absolutely terrifying here we go it was
terrifying watching you go through that
what Adam didn't know is that as
frightening as his experience was
it had an astonishing real-world impact
well it was a typical day it was right
before Easter and I got up and got Emily
up we got her ready to go I left about
4:30 in the morning and I got a boat
three miles down the road and I hit a
patch of slushy snow and went off and
into the water
and I looked and their car was filling
up with water
it was so happening so fast I crawled
through the vehicle got it into the
backseat with Emily unstrapped her from
her car seat and I tried the driver's
side door that door wouldn't open
I had Emily in my arms trying to keep
her out of the water and I'm going oh my
gosh
I need to get us out of here and then
you know the Mythbusters thing came to
mind and that was like okay I have to
wait even though I didn't want to I had
to wait total pressure equalized in the
vehicle so I could get the door open I
waited until that moment pushed the door
open and it opened like nothing and I
kind of swam walked and I kind of held
them a link above my head to keep her
out of the water and got onto the road
I still get emotional I still every year
on April 3rd I still kind of go yeah
this could have been the day meeting her
weren't cuter you know wow I I don't
know what to say to that
that's intense we're not just blowing
things up here